I've got a matrix a and it's an M by n
matrix it has M rows and n columns so I
can write it in fairly general terms
like this the first row would be a11
first row first column a12 first row
second column all the way to I have n
columns so a1 and first row and column
and then the second row would look like
this a second row first column a second
row second column all the way to a
second row and column and we'll just
keep doing that all the way down until
you get to the m p--
row the M throw would look like this
each of these are the entries in each of
the rows or columns depending on how you
want to look at it so this is going to
be a sub M 1 M throw first column a sub
M 2 and you go all the way to a sub M
and this is our matrix right here this
is that is my matrix a now I'm going to
define the transpose of this matrix I'm
going to define the transpose of this
matrix transpose transpose of this
matrix as a with this superscript T and
it's essentially and this is going to be
my definition it's essentially the
matrix a with all the rows and the
columns swapped so my matrix a transpose
is going to be a n by M matrix notice
notice to set M rows and n columns now
this is going to have n rows and M
columns so what is this guy going to
look like what is he going to look like
where I'm going to swap my rows in my
columns so my first row becomes my first
column so I'm going to have a 1 1 that
entries still going to be in that
position but now this entry is not going
to be right here a 1 2 in my second row
I have what I used to have in my sec in
my second row first column I'm now going
to have
I had in my second column first row I'm
just going to go down all the way to a
1n and that makes this not a I n a 1 and
that makes sense because I'm going to
have n columns I had n I sorry I now
have n rows I had n columns before now I
have n rows now this row when I
transpose it when I transpose it's going
to look like this a 2 1 a 2 2 all the
way down to a 2n and if you could it
might be a little confusing for you
right now to have this notation right
there because everything we've done so
far we've always said hey this first
number is the row and the second number
is the column that's what we did up here
what I'm doing here you can ignore that
reference to the rows and columns you
can just say whatever we had here in my
first row second column
I now have here so when you look at this
transpose don't take these subscripts
too literally or now you can kind of
reverse your interpretation this is now
the first column second row this was the
second row first column so these are the
I don't want you get too confused with
these subscripts we're just keep in mind
we're taking all of the rows and turning
them into the columns to get the
transpose and then you just keep doing
this you just keep doing this and then
this M row will now become the empty
column am-1 am-2
all the way down to a m n all the way
down to a MN so this entry is now that
entry if you know this entry is now that
entry that entry is now this entry I
think you get the idea this is what a
transpose is and sometimes when you do
it in the abstract it can be a little
confusing and we'll especially
appreciate that once we do some of the
proofs involving the transpose but
actually taking the transpose of an
actual matrix with actual numbers
shouldn't be too difficult so let's
start with the 2 by 2 case and I'll try
to color code it as best as I can so
let's say I have the matrix let's say I
define a let's do B now
find a let's say B B is equal to the
matrix let's say it's equal to the
matrix
one two three four those yellows are
pretty close but what does B transpose
going to look like B transpose is going
to be equal to you switch the rows in
the column so the first row will now
become the first column one two and the
second row will now become the second
column three or or you could view it the
other way the first column now became
the first row and the second column now
became the second row let's do an
example let's head of even doing a two
by three let me or three by three let me
do one that might be a little bit more a
little more challenging I think this
will make things clearer so let's say I
have the matrix C let me say I have the
matrix C right here and let me make it a
pretty big matrix let's say it is a four
by three matrix right here so let me
just throw some numbers in there one
zero minus one to seven
I want to do it in different colors let
me do that in a different color so then
I get to seven minus five then I get
four minus three two and I have to do
one more row here so let me just make
that minus 1 3 and zero that is my
matrix C so what is let me do that in I
like to be aesthetically pleasing so let
me close the bracket in the same color
so what does C transpose going to be so
C transpose let me do that in a
different color C transpose is now going
to be a 3 by 4 matrix and essentially
it's going to be the matrix C with all
the rows swapped for the columns or all
the columns swapped for the rows so it's
now going to be a 3 by 4 matrix so now
I'm going to be a 3 by 4 matrix and that
first row there is not going to become
the first column 1 0 minus 1 the second
row
here is now going to become the second
column to seven minus five I didn't use
the exact same green but you get the
idea this third row will become the
third column four minus three two and
then finally the fourth row will become
the fourth column minus one three and
zero so all we did is if this guy was
let's say this guy was in the position
this guy was in the second row second
row second row third column third column
now that same guy is in the what he is
in the second column second column and
the third row the third row all we did
is switch the rows and the columns we
could do with another let's see let's do
it with this one right here this guy
right here is in the third row third row
one two three and the second column
second column and when you go down here
this guy is now in the third column
third column and the second row and the
second row that's all a transpose is and
just as a little interesting thing what
happens if we take the transpose of the
transpose so what happens if we take C
transpose and then transpose that what
is that going to be equal to well to go
from C to C transpose we switched all
the rows and the columns all the entries
with the rows and the columns but when
you take the transpose again remember
let's just focus on this guy this was
second row third column you took the
transpose he becomes second column and
third row if you were to take the
transpose again of that he would then
become the second row and third column
again so C transpose is the transpose of
C transpose is just equal to C you're
swapping all the columns when you take
the transpose and when you take the
transpose again you swap them all back
that's all that means
anyway hopefully you found that useful